new at 11 more develop development
downtown this time it is the north side
of the arts district that's seeing some
major changes as a new hotel backed by a
celebrity chef opens its doors on main
street sasha loftis joins us now live
with more on what this could mean for
the area's future sasha
denise those we spoke with tonight say
they're just happy this area is getting
a little love now the business owners we
spoke with here in the arts district say
this hotel and the name attached to it
could really mark an entirely new era
for this neighborhood
ready or not las vegas is growing again
you can start to see the growth even on
the strip it's all coming this way
valley native robert ammario says he's
excited to see downtown expand more
specifically the arts district just
north of charleston
and it's about to get even busier with
the english hotel opening next week here
on main street i think it's a game
changer for the area the 74-room
property is backed by celebrity chef
todd english who will open on-site
restaurant the pepper club eduardo
cordova who owns nearby bar the garden
says this kind of offering and the clout
that comes with it will really put the
area on the map they can stay here and
they can come out and party here and go
to the restaurants we have you know
amazing offerings in the neighborhood he
can't wait to see the transformation and
calls himself lucky to be a part of it
super excited just seeing all the growth
and the progress and being in one of the
most exciting neighborhoods up and
coming neighborhoods in the nation while
robert says he's happy to enjoy
everything this neighborhood and our
entire community has to offer that's big
that's really big
now the english hotel will hold its
ribbon cutting ceremony this coming
tuesday february 22nd at 2 22 p.m they
are now accepting reservations online
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now